jason recorrió en bicicleta desde su
casa hasta la estación del tren con una
rapidez promedio de 10 kilómetros por
hora después abordó el tren y viajó
hasta la ciudad con una rapidez promedio
de 50 kilómetros por hora si la
distancia total del viaje fue de 30
kilómetros y el viaje en total duró una
hora cuántos kilómetros viajo jason en
tren así que lo primero que voy a hacer
es definir variables y voy a decir que
de zubin de este tema es la cantidad de
distancia que viajo jason en tren la
distancia que viajo jason en tren y por
lo tanto de manera análoga de subíndice
voy a decir que es la distancia que
viajo jason en bicicleta la distancia
que recorrió en bicicleta muy bien ahora
que ya tengo estas dos nuevas variables
yo sé que la distancia total fue de 30
km por lo tanto si yo sumo estas dos
distancias tiene que ser igual a 30 la
distancia que viajo jason entre en más
la distancia que viajo jason en
bicicleta esto tiene que ser igual a 30
y yo
como todo está dado en kilómetros y todo
está dando en horas no voy a tener que
cambiar unidades ahora después me dice
que el viaje entero duró una hora y
seguramente en este momento vas a decir
o no pero estamos hablando de tiempo y
por lo tanto tendremos que meter dos
nuevas variables el tiempo del tren y el
tiempo de la bicicleta sin embargo lo
que quiero que recordemos es una fórmula
que hemos visto varias veces en los
vídeos de física que dice que la
distancia es igual a la rapidez por el
tiempo y si divido ambos lados entre la
rapidez
me quedaría que el tiempo es igual a la
distancia entre la rapidez el tiempo es
igual a la distancia entre la rapidez y
justo esto voy a utilizar porque
entonces puedo ver el tiempo como una
función de la distancia que es justo lo
que quiero fíjate bien el tiempo del
tren es igual según esta fórmula a la
distancia del tren entre la rapidez
promedio que hicimos en el tren pero ese
dato me lo dan la repite es promedio que
hicimos en el tren es de 50 kilómetros
por hora por lo tanto como todos dan
kilómetros y todos están horas voy a
dividir entre 50 el tiempo del tren es
igual
el tren entre 50 y de igual manera si yo
pienso en la bicicleta el tiempo en la
bicicleta va a ser la distancia de la
bicicleta entre la rapidez promedio que
hicimos en la bicicleta que fueron 10
kilómetros por hora
perfecto y ya que tengo estas dos
entonces yo sé que la suma del tiempo
del tren más la suma del tiempo en la
bicicleta tiene que ser igual a una hora
este dato es muy importante porque
entonces me voy a tomar la suma de estos
dos tiempos pero en función de la
distancia y lo voy a ser igual a una
hora entonces este dato es muy
importante y voy a utilizar estas dos
ecuaciones que tengo aquí y entonces qué
ecuación me va a quedar de sumar estos
dos tiempos vamos a escribirlo aquí
abajo con un nuevo color bueno que la
distancia del tren entre 50 esto estoy
hablando del tiempo del tren más la
distancia de la bicicleta entre 10 estoy
hablando del tiempo de la bicicleta esto
tiene que ser igual a una hora es lo que
me dice este renglón y ojo no te
confundas lo único que hice fue tomarme
la suma de los dos tiempos del tiempo
del tren y del tiempo de la bicicleta
pero lo sustituye como función
de la distancia para que así me queden
dos ecuaciones con dos incógnitas y
entonces pueda encontrar la solución de
este problema es decir la distancia que
recordemos el tren es justo lo que yo
quiero atrás de esta variable vamos y
bueno la forma más sencilla de resolver
esto y lo que se me ocurre es a mirar si
yo tengo en la ecuación de arriba tal
cual y johann logró que la ecuación de
abajo tenga aquí un menos la distancia
en bicicleta entonces podría sumar estas
dos ecuaciones así que mejor déjenme
poner esta ecuación a qué lado la
distancia del tren más la distancia y la
bicicleta es igual a 30 y por otra parte
está esta de que es la que quiero
convertir en menos la distancia de la
bicicleta y bueno la forma más fácil de
hacerlo es multiplicar esta ecuación de
ambos lados por menos 10
si yo multiplico a esta ecuación de
ambos lados por menos 10 voy a obtener
lo que hicieron fíjate bien cuando yo
multiplique por menos 10 y divida entre
10 me va a quedar menos 1 y menos 1 por
la distancia y la bicicleta es justo lo
que quiero entonces que me queda de esto
bueno 10 entre 50 es lo mismo que un
quinto pero con este signo menos
al menos un quinto de la distancia del
tren y después me queda menos 10 entre
10 esto es igual al menos 1 por la
distancia de la bicicleta entonces me
queda menos la distancia y la bicicleta
esto es igual a menos 10 muy bien y yo
quería ser la distancia de la bicicleta
negativa para que ahora sí pueda
resolver este sistema de ecuaciones por
el método de suma resta de una manera
bastante sencilla porque yo voy a sumar
estas dos ecuaciones y esto se va a
cancelar entonces me queda la distancia
del tren menos un quinto de la distancia
del tren bueno la distancia del tren es
lo mismo que cinco quintos de la
distancia del tren menos un quinto de la
distancia del tren me queda cuatro
quintos de la distancia del tren cuatro
quintos de la distancia del tren esto es
igual a 30 menos 10 lo cual es 20 y
ahora si yo lo que quiero saber es la
distancia del tren y tengo una fracción
pues tengo que multiplicar por el
recíproco de una fracción pero atrás y
poco de una fracción es muy sencillo lo
único que hay que hacer es pasar el
denominador el numerador y el numerador
al denominador y entonces voy a
multiplicar por 5 cuartos de ambos lados
de la ecuación entonces estos dos se
cancelan y me queda que la distancia del
tren es igual a 20 por 5 cuartos
y yo he vivido 20 entre 4 entonces este
de aquí me da 5 y 4 entre 41 y entonces
me queda 5 por 5 lo cual es 25 perfecto
la distancia del tren es 25 kilómetros
que es justo lo que yo quería este es el
resultado de mi problema y además con
esta distancia del tren podría obtener
todo lo demás la distancia de la
bicicleta en los dos tiempos etcétera y
más aún de esta ecuación puede obtener
de una manera muy sencilla que la
distancia de la bicicleta tiene que ser
5 km